in this video you're going to learn how
to work with the Law of Sines and the
law of cosines this is designed to be a
complete guide to teach you about how to
work with both law of Science and law of
cosines we're going to talk about how to
find missing sides how to find missing
angles and triangles that don't involve
a right angle so when you had a triangle
with a right angle we just used a
regular trigonometry our sine cosine
tangent this is different this is the
Law of Sines law of cosines we're also
going to talk about some special cases
where you could get two triangles or
only one triangle or maybe even no
triangle is possible we're also going to
talk about how to completely solve the
triangle mean find all the sides and all
the angles so let's dive in and start
with talking about the Law of Sines and
when we work with the Law of Sines this
is the formula that we're going to be
working with it's the sine of angle a
over its side opposite which we call
side a is equal to the ratio sine of
angle B over its side opposite which is
called side B and that's equal to the
ratio of sine of angle C over its side
opposite which we call side C now when
you work with the Law of Sines you only
need to use two of these ratios to form
a proportion so what you want to notice
is that that we use a capital letter for
the Angles and we use a lowercase letter
for the sides if we talk about this as
angle a then across from angle a we call
side a and you're just trying to find a
pair so what I mean by that is let's
look at example one I like to think
about the angle and the side opposite as
a pair so here I can see here's angle B
and side B here's angle C and side C and
notice with those two pairs we can form
a proportion and we only have one
unknown quantity so what we're going to
do is we're going to say the sine
of 40 degrees
over its side opposite which is 6.
equals the sine of 100 degrees
over its side opposite which is V now
you have to be a little bit careful
sometimes the number six and the letter
B look very similar so I'm just going to
circle this B so we know that that's our
variable now we're going to cross
multiply to get rid of the fraction so
that's going to be 6 times sine of 100
equals B times
sine of 40.
and then if I divide both sides by the
sine of 40 degrees
that's going to give us our variable B
by itself
okay now we're going to go to the
calculator now make sure when you're
working with your calculator that your
mode is in degrees and so we're working
with degrees otherwise you're going to
get a different answer so 6 times sine
of 100
divided by the sine of 40. and I'm
getting about
9.19 so I'll just put approximately 9.19
and that's this missing side right here
now sometimes when you're learning about
Law of Sines your book or your teacher
might actually take the reciprocal of
all of these ratios so they might say
side a over sine of angle a side B over
sine of angle B so they're basically
just flipping it I prefer to do it this
way it doesn't really matter you just
don't want to mix and match so if you
either put the sides in the numerator
and the sine of the angle in the
denominator or vice versa
now let's take a look at another example
here now for number two
what would you do on this one well you
can see we've got 35 degrees and we're
looking for the side across from that
angle so let's think of these as like a
pair I sometimes like to Circle them
and then over here we've got 20 degrees
okay and we don't know the side opposite
okay so that means we have too many
variables right well what do we do well
in this case we notice we've had these
two angles so we can add them up and
subtract from 180 to find that missing
angle so let's go ahead and do that so
this comes out to 55 degrees 180 minus
55 is a 125
degrees right so now look what we have
we have this angle e and its side
opposite a so we've got a pair and we've
got a pair and we only have one unknown
so that's the key so let's write this
out we've got the sine of 35 degrees
over its side opposite which is side D
equals the sine of 125 degrees
over its side opposite which is 8. now
we're going to cross multiply to get rid
of our fractions so you know the cross
product property so this is going to be
D times the sine of 125 degrees equals
this diagonal multiplied together eight
times the sine
of 35 degrees now we'll just divide both
sides by sine of 125 to get our variable
d by itself whatever you do to the left
you want to do to the right
and now we're going to go to our
calculator so let's see we've got eight
sine of 35
divided by the sine of 125. okay so this
is coming out to
approximately 5.60
and that's the length of this missing
side let's take a look at the next
example okay in example number three now
we're solving for the missing angle in
example one in example two we were
solving for the missing side so this is
a little bit different type of problem
but notice what we have here we have a
pair we have angle G which is 42 degrees
over its side opposite which is 10.
and we've got this angle I over its side
opposite which is 12. so let's go ahead
and make our proportion using our Law of
Sines and we're going to say the sine of
42 degrees over 10 that ratio is equal
to the sine of angle I
over its side opposite which is 12. now
what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to try to get this sine of I by itself
by doing the opposite multiplying both
sides by 12.
okay and now what we're going to do is
to solve for I we're going to take the
sine inverse of both sides so I is equal
to this sine inverse
of this whole quantity here so 12 times
the sine of 42 degrees
over 10. so let's go to the calculator
let's see what that comes out to we've
got 12 and you can do this in steps if
you want 12 times sine of 42 divided by
10 and I'm going to take the sine
inverse of that previous answer so I'm
getting 53 approximately
53.41
degrees so that is the measure of angle
I
now in example number four
let's look at this one now we're
Switching gears to the law of cosines
and we talk about the law of cosines
let's pretend like we're going to do the
Law of Sines like say for example if I
said here's an angle and I'm solving for
the side opposite but then I'd have to
know this angle
and this side opposite or this angle and
this side opposite you basically you
only want to have one unknown so if I
have two unknowns Law of Sines is not
going to work we use the angle on the
side opposite as a pair like that so
sometimes students say well how do I
know when to use law of science or law
of cosines now here's an easy way to
remember the only time you really have
to use law of cosines is when they just
give you either three sides side side
side
or side angle side what do I mean by
that so if they just gave us three side
lengths and nothing else you'd have to
use law of cosines to start off with if
they give you side angle sides see where
the angle is in between two sides then
again you're going to have to use the
law of cosines to start off with
so that's what we're faced with here is
a side angle side so let's go ahead and
do the law of cosines now
when you look at the law of cosines
there's three different forms of the
equation you might notice in your
textbook or that your teacher might show
you they'll say c squared equals a
squared plus b squared minus 2 a b
cosine C or B squared equals a squared
plus c squared minus 2 AC cosine B it
gets a little bit confusing but I want
you to kind of recognize a couple
patterns here one is that see if you're
solving for side C okay
this is angle C over here so what I
think of is that they're across from
each other in the diagram angle C and
side C and they're across from each
other in the formula then the other two
variables A and B A and B those are the
sides that make up that angle C like
look over here so for example if we have
side B and angle B they're across from
each other in the Triangle they're
across from each other in the formula
and if we're working with the angle b or
side B then the other two variables here
A and C A and C are the two sides that
make up that angle B same thing here
you've got a side a and angle a they're
across from each other in the Triangle
across from each other in the formula
the other two variables B and C are the
two sides that make up the angle so you
can extrapolate that and make kind of
like a generic law of cosines formula
which you might think about as this
right here where it's the side squared
we'll just call this x squared okay is
across from our angle X okay and then
the other two sides side one and side
two that make up that angle
go here okay so you might want to
generalize and think about it like that
but going over to this problem right
here using our general formula here
we're solving for PSI J that's over here
side x we're going to say J squared
is equal to psi 1 squared plus PSI 2
squared these are the two sides that
make up our angle so that's going to be
8 squared plus 10 squared minus 2 times
the two sides multiplied together 8
times 10 times the cosine of the angle
in between those two sides which is 60
degrees
now this is J squared we just want to
solve for PSI J so what we're going to
have to do is we're going to have to
take the square root
of both sides the square and the square
root cancel and we get our PSI J now you
can do this in steps if you want like I
might put all this in my calculator and
then take the square root of that answer
so let's see we've got 8 square which is
64 plus 10 squared which is a hundred
minus 2 times 8 times 10 times the
cosine of 60 again make sure your
calculator is in degrees and then we're
going to take the square root of that
answer
so I'm getting about
9.17 so approximately
9.17 is the length of side J let's take
a look at some more law of cosines
examples okay let's take a look at
example number five now notice in
example number five we're given three
sides so side side and remember when we
have side side or side angle side we
have to use our law of cosines and
what's interesting about this problem as
opposed to the last one is we're solving
for the missing angle so we're going to
go ahead and use our generic law of
cosines formula but we're going to be
solving here for angle X we know side x
which is the side across so we're going
to start off with 7 squared equals
5 squared plus 6 squared those are the
two sides that make up our angle minus 2
times those two same sides again five
and six and then the cosine of I'll just
call this angle n here or in our formula
here this is like our angle X
Okay now what's interesting here is we
have to get this cosine n by itself I'll
just circle it on one side of our
equation and then we'll have to take the
cosine inverse to solve for angle n so
whenever you're solving for the missing
angle you're going to have to do the
inverse trig function
so let's do this in Step 7 squared is
49. 5 squared is 25 6 squared is 36 2
times 5 is 10 times 6 is 60.
cosine angle n
25 plus 36 is 61. and what I'm going to
do is I'm going to take 49 minus 61. so
we'll just subtract 61 from both sides
that's giving us a negative 12 equals
negative 60 cosine angle n again we're
trying to get cosine n by itself so
we're going to divide both sides by
negative 60.
that comes out to 1 5 or 0.2
and now we're going to take the cosine
inverse of both sides to get angle n by
itself so n is equal to the cosine
inverse of 0.2 let's go to the
calculator see what that angle comes out
to you might have to press your second
key
and let's see 0.2
okay I'm getting
78.46 approximately
78.46 degrees and that's our missing
angle n
now let's take a look at number six okay
so for number six we're solving for this
missing angle again just like a number
5. but now we're starting to get into
some what we call
um kind of like ambiguous cases or some
cases where maybe there's no no possible
answer and again when we're given three
sides side side or side angle side we
think about law of cosines
but what's interesting about this
triangle is you see how five and six
only add up to 11. so so five plus six
is not greater than 12. there's
something called the triangle inequality
theorem which basically means that any
two sides have to add up to more than
the third side otherwise there's no
triangle possible now you might be
saying Mario what are you talking about
so say this side here is 12. imagine if
we really Drew this to scale because
this is some anybody can draw a triangle
and throw numbers on the sides but in
reality right say for example this was
six and this is five even if I rotate
this side down and this side down you
see how there's like a one unit Gap
there it's like a drawbridge it's not
going to be able to reach you know it's
the two short those two sides so these
two sides have to after more than the
third side otherwise no triangles
possible now you might be saying what
happens if I don't notice that well you
can go ahead and do the law of cosines
just like we did here in this last
problem number five but when you go to
solve for this angle angle you get an
error on your calculator and you'll say
what's going on and then you can go back
and say oh I miss the fact that you know
it didn't satisfy the triangle
inequality theorem okay so for this one
no triangle possible not possible can't
be drawn that way so number seven now
what do we think about this one
okay now this one is also kind of like a
special case and I didn't want to throw
this all at you at the very beginning
about what we call the ambiguous case
but we're going to start getting into
What's called the ambiguous case and
this is called the
side side angle condition okay and what
is a side side angle condition means it
means that there's the potential for two
triangles one triangle or no triangle
and so see how as you go see how as you
go around the triangle side side angle
okay or you could do angle side side
that's when you have the potential for
two one or no triangles but what's
interesting about this triangle when
this angle is obtuse meaning more than
you want to make sure that the side
across from that obtuse angle is longer
than the side adjacent or next to that
angle so in a triangle you might
remember this from geometry the longest
side is always across from the largest
angle the smallest side is across from
the smallest angle the medium side is
across from the medium angle right
so in this case there's no triangle
possible now you might try to do the Law
of Sines because you can see here's an
angle and a side opposite here's an
angle and a side opposite you say okay
I've got two pairs let me do my Law of
Sines again you're going to go to the
calculator
and you're going to get an error and so
then you might be saying why am I
getting an error because you can't
really draw this triangle if we were to
draw it more to real life proportions
say this is nine this is eight it's like
it it doesn't reach you know let's take
a look at a few more examples
okay for number eight we're going to
dive deeper into this ambiguous case
situation so remember ambiguous cases
when they give us side side angle so
let's just write that down so whenever
you before you dive into a problem just
always look at the triangle just say am
I given side side angle if I am just
kind of pause for a minute and say let
me analyze this and see if there's one
two or no triangles possible how do you
actually go about doing this
what you want to do is you want to drop
an altitude altitude means like the
height of the triangle I'll just call
this H okay for the height let's figure
out what this height is so you can see
we have this right triangle you're
familiar with your sohcahtoa from your
right triangle trigonometry so we're
going to say the sine of 30 equals the
opposite side over the hypotenuse so
let's calculate that so sine of 30
equals opposite over hypotenuse multiply
both sides by 10.
and sine of 30 we know is a half times
10 is 5 or you can do that on the
calculator okay so we see how this
height equals 5.
okay now
when you have an acute angle like this a
angle that's less than 90 and the side
side angle condition
you look at this side across from that
acute angle if this side okay is shorter
than this side like imagine for example
let's let's change this instead of being
six let's say that this was four now if
I was to draw that
okay to scale you see the problem here
with 4 if I rotate this
it's going to be too short it's like
it's like it's not going to reach the
other side that means there's no
triangle possible you can stop right
there you don't have to do any
calculations so it's like a Time Saver
imagine if this side here wasn't four
say if it was like five well let's draw
that to scale so now if I if it's five
you can see when you rotate it it's
going to just barely touch this opposite
side that means you're going to have a
right triangle so exactly one triangle
right
what happens if this side here let's go
back to the original problem as I drew
it let's say that this side was 6.
now when this side across from the acute
angle is in between the altitude and the
side adjacent see how this is five and
ten so a six is in between 5 and 10.
that means there's two triangles
possible why two triangles possible well
because we don't know what angle B is
which means that this can act like a
hinge I could actually rotate the side
like this
and you can see we're getting this
triangle possible or this triangle over
here possible okay and then there's one
other scenario and that's where this
side here is longer than this side here
so say for example if this was like 16
if it was actually 16 it would be like
way over here if I go to rotate it
it's not going to intersect this other
side it's going to like there's only
going to be one triangle possible so did
you follow that so let's do that again
so if you have a side side angle
condition the side across from the acute
angle if it's shorter than the altitude
no triangle possible if it's equal to
the altitude it's a right triangle if
this side is in between the altitude and
the side adjacent you get two triangles
that's what we're going to do right now
in just a minute
and if this side here is longer than the
side adjacent okay that means it can
only go this way you can't rotate it
over here it's only going to be one
triangle possible okay so now in this
two triangle possible scenario let's
draw our two triangles so we have the
original triangle which is this one
right here okay and we have this little
triangle over here so let me draw the
little triangle it kind of looks
something like this
okay so this is still going to be 30
degrees this is still going to be 10.
this is still going to be angle A and B
and c and this side over here is still
going to be 6.
so then the question is what should we
do first say we want to solve this
triangle we want to find all the Angles
and all the sides well because I have an
angle and a side opposite and I don't
have this angle but I have this side
opposite we have to solve for angle C so
let's do that let's say the sine of
angle C over its side opposite 10 is
equal to the sine of 30 over its side
opposite
6. okay so we're going to multiply both
sides by 10.
to get the sine of C by itself and then
we're going to take the sine inverse
of this quantity to get C so let's do
that so sine of 30
is a half times 10 is 5 so that's 5 6
and we're going to take the sine inverse
of 5 6. okay that's coming out to
I'm going to just turn around to the
10th to keep this a little bit simpler
on this problem so 56.4 degrees now see
how this is 56.4 degrees right here but
remember when we took this side and we
rotated it see like this and this is 6
and this is six what kind of a triangle
is that where the two sides are
congruent it's an isosceles triangle
what do you know about the base angles
of an isosceles triangle
they're congruent so if this is 56.4
this is 56.4 how much is this angle next
to the 56.4 degree angle
that's going to be 180 minus 56.4
which is 123
.6 degrees see so this remember this
little triangle here that's our other
possible triangle that could be drawn
given that limited information of side
side angle
so this angle here was just 180 minus
the 56.4 now notice what we have here
we've got this angle this angle if I
want to find angle B here all I have to
do is add these up and subtract from
180. so let's do that 180 minus 30.
minus 56.4 so this is coming out to
93.6 this angle over here we're going to
subtract from 180 so 180 minus 30 minus
123.6 is 26.4
okay so that's that angle
and now all we're left to solve for is
this side here B across from angle B
same thing here this side B across from
angle B so how can we do that now
when I do these problems I try to go
back and use the original values if at
all possible because those are exact
whereas 56.4 that's rounded so to be a
little bit more accurate I'm going to
say sine of 30 over 6.
is equal to sine of 93.6
over its side opposite which is side B
we can do the same thing for this
triangle here we could do sine of 30
over 6.
is equal to sine of 26.4
over side B so let's go ahead and solve
both of these so I'm going to cross
multiply
so that gives us 6 sine of
93.6 equals B times the sine of 30.
divide both sides by sine of 30.
and that gives us the side B for this
triangle so let's do that 6 sine of 93.6
divided by sine of 30.
okay it's coming out to 11 well it's
12.0 we're going to round to the nearest
tenth on this one so 12.0 for this side
right here
and then if we do this problem 6 times
the sine of 26.4 is equal to B times
sine of 30 divide both sides by sine of
30 to get B by itself
and let's see what that comes out to
okay 5.3 approximately
so that's this side right here so what
we did in this problem was not only
determine whether there was one two or
no triangles because there was two
triangles we actually split it up into
the two triangles and we solved each
triangle individually to find all the
missing angles all the missing sides
we're going to do some more examples but
I just want to point out to you that
there was two side B's there was two
angle C's and there was two angle B's so
two different triangles let's take a
look at the next example okay for number
nine why don't you try number nine on
your own if you can what we're going to
do for a b and c is we're going to
determine are there one triangle two
triangles or no triangles possible so
see if you can do this so for letter A
9A what do you think one triangle two
triangle or no triangles well notice we
have this side side angle ambiguous case
or the side side angle condition so what
I like to do is I like to drop an
altitude
like so and now we have a right triangle
we can find out what that height is so
that height is
um
sine of 41 equals H over eight multiply
both sides by eight that's going to be
eight times the sine of 41 degrees that
comes out to 5.2
Okay now what's interesting is remember
when the side across from the acute
angle is longer than the side adjacent
there's only one triangle possible so we
really didn't even need to find the
altitude on this particular problem
because the side opposite the acute
angle is longer than the side adjacent
so we're just going to say one triangle
possible on this and we don't need to
solve it for this problem but for letter
B now what do you think one triangle two
triangular or no triangle possible
well if I was going to do this problem I
would drop an altitude
and I would find out what this height is
so I'd say sine of 26 equals H over 7
multiply both sides by 7 so that's going
to be 7 times the sine of 26 degrees
that comes out to 3.1
okay so let's write that down 3.1 now
notice
that the side across from the 26 degrees
is shorter
than the altitude see if I was really to
draw this to scale 3 is only going to be
like this when I go to rotate it it's
not going to reach since the height is
3.1 so in this case there's no triangle
possible
and then for letter C what do you think
on this one two triangles one triangle
or no triangle possible if I was going
to do this again I would drop an
altitude solve for the height so sine of
35 let's write this one down
equals opposite over hypotenuse multiply
both sides by six
so that comes out to 6 sine of 35 3.4
now notice 5 the side of crossing the
acute angle is in between the altitude
and the side adjacent that means we can
actually rotate this
like that to form a second triangle so
in this case there's actually two
triangles possible
okay so now let's go to number 10 we're
going to talk about how again to solve
the entire triangle so see if you can
pause the video and try this one find
all the angles all the missing sides
basically find everything remember a
triangle is made up of three angles
three sides in this case they're giving
us three pieces of information we have
to find the other three missing pieces
so how would you do this one
first thing I would do is I would look
at the information that I'm given I'm
given a side angle side see the angle in
between the two sides that tells me law
of cosines I have to start off with and
I'm going to solve for this side across
side w
now you can use the generic form we've
been talking about here which should be
this side here squared
is equal to the two other sides that
make up this angle so 7 squared plus six
squared minus two times seven times six
times the cosine of 43 degrees take the
square root of both sides to get W by
itself and then let's see what that
comes out to so 7 squared is 49 6
squared is 36. minus 2 times 7 times 6
times the cosine of 43
and then take the square root of that
answer I'm getting about
4.85 so approximately
4.85
is this missing side now notice we have
an angle and a side opposite we can
think of that as a pair
and let's say we want to solve for angle
y we have a side and we'll just have
this missing angle so let's go ahead and
do our Law of Sines notice when you do
the law of cosines first you only have
to do it at most one time and then you
can switch over to Law of Sines which is
a lot
simpler and quicker so sine of angle y
over 7. equals the sine of 43 over
4.85 multiply both sides by 7 to get
sine of Y by itself and then take the
sine inverse
of that answer so let's go ahead and do
that so sine of 43
times 7 divided by 4.85 take the sine
inverse of that answer so it's coming
out to approximately
79.84 degrees
okay now we just have to solve for angle
X up here and you can see that these two
angles plus this third angle have to add
up to 180. so if we do 180 minus these
two angles
we can find that missing angle X let's
see what that comes out to
looks like we're getting 57
.16 degrees and you solve the triangle
you found all the Angles and all the
sides let's take a look at two more
examples where you're solving the entire
triangle see if you can try these on
your own okay see if you can pause the
video on Trend number 11 so we're going
to solve the entire triangle find all
the missing sides and all the missing
angles so how would you do this one
well if I was going to do it I would
kind of look at the information that
we're given here it looks like we're
given side side so remember when it's
side side you're going to want to start
off with law of cosines or side angle
side law of cosines so in this case
we're going to start with law of cosines
and oftentimes teachers will say well go
ahead and start by solving for the angle
that's across from the
longest side so we'll start off by
solving for angle I now you might want
to analyze the triangle inequality
theorem to make sure that these two
sides add up to More Than This Side so
that's 15 or these two sides add up more
to this side or these two sides add up
to More Than This Side so any two sides
have to add up to more than the third
side in this case it looks like it
satisfies that triangle inequality
theorem so using the law of cosines
let's start with this generic formula
we're going to solve for angle I so
we're going to say the side across from
angle I that's over here x so that's
going to be 11 squared
equals the two sides that make up the
angle so that's going to be 6 squared
plus 9 squared minus 2 times the same
two sides 6 times 9 times the cosine of
angle I
so our goal is to get cosine of I by
itself so that we can then take the
cosine inverse and solve for the angle I
okay so let's go ahead and simplify a
little bit 11 squared is 121
6 squared is 36 9 squared is 81
699 is 54 times 2 is 108.
some students mistakenly try to subtract
these two numbers but you want to think
of this as a group so I would add these
together and subtract from 121 so let's
see what that is
36 plus 81 is 117.
and if we subtract 117 from both sides
we get 4
. now we can divide oops this is angle I
here cosine of angle I
so we can divide both sides by negative
and take the cosine inverse so I is
equal to the cosine inverse of negative
4 over 108. so let's see what that comes
out to
92 point 1 2 so if I equals
92.12 degrees
now we need to solve for angle n or
angle W so let's go ahead and solve for
angle W so we'll just do the sine of w
over its side opposite which is 9 is
equal to the sine of
92.12 over its side Ops which is 11. so
notice we only did the law of cosines
once then we can switch the Law of Sines
we'll go ahead and multiply both sides
by 9.
and then to find W we're going to take
the sine inverse so w equals the sine
inverse of this whole quantity so let's
go ahead and do that sine of 92.12
times 9 divided by 11
take the sine inverse
and we're getting 54.85
and that's for this angle
and then we know all the angles in a
triangle add up to 180 so we can take
180 minus
92.12 minus the 54.85 and it looks like
for angle n we're getting 33.03
degrees and we've solve the triangle all
the sides all the angles let's do one
last example see if you can do this one
on your own okay see if you can pause
the video and do this last one on your
own example number 12. what do you think
about this one
well if I was going to do it I would
look at it and I'd notice that they're
giving a side side angle that's that
ambiguous case that we've been talking
about here and there and side side angle
we can see that the side opposite acute
angle is not longer than the side
adjacent so if this was longer if this
was let's say like you know 12 or
something there would only be one
triangle possible so to analyze this
let's go ahead and drop an altitude this
height here and let's figure out what
that height is so the sine of 54 degrees
equals opposite over hypotenuse multiply
both sides by 9 to get H by itself
and let's see what 9 times the sine of
54 is that's 7.3
okay now notice that this side eight is
in between the altitude and the side
adjacent that means that we can actually
rotate this
to form a second triangle let's draw the
two triangles so we can see them clearly
here we've got this triangle
which is like our original triangle m a
t
okay and then let's see this is 54
degrees and this is 9 and this is eight
and then when we rotate it we get this
little
small triangle kind of like this
okay and this is still going to be m
a t this is still going to be 54 degrees
this is still going to be 9 and this is
still going to be 8.
okay so what we need to do is we need to
solve for angle T over here because we
have 54 and 8 that's a pair T and nine
that's a pair so angle in the side
opposite form a pair we can do our Law
of Sines so let's start off by using
this triangle here we'll say sine of 54
over 8.
is equal to the sine of angle T over 9.
multiply both sides by 9.
and then we'll take the sine inverse
of this whole quantity so let's see what
that is so 9
sine of 54
divided by 8 take the sine inverse
that comes out so I'm going to round to
the nearest tenth let's just do the
nearest tenth on this so This t comes
out to approximately
65.5 degrees
65.5 degrees now remember if this angle
is 65.5 when we rotate it if this side
here is a this side here is 8 and if
it's an isosceles triangle the base
angles are congruent which means that
this is 65.5 so that angle next to it
right here which corresponds to this
angle right here is going to be 180
minus
65.5 so that's 114
.5
degrees okay now when we have two angles
in a triangle we can find the missing
third angle by subtracting from 180 so
180 minus 54 minus 65.5 gives us 60.5
degrees and this angle up here we'll do
180 minus 54 minus 114.5
which gives us 11.5
okay now all we have to do is solve for
side a in both these triangles so over
here
let's do sine of 54 over 8. notice I'm
going back to those original numbers
because they're not rounded equals the
sine of 60.5
over side a and then we'll do the same
thing over here we'll do the sine of 54.
over 8. is equal to the sine of 11.5
degrees over this side a
okay so let's go ahead and solve so
we're going to cross multiply so that's
8 times the sine of 60.5
equals a times the sine of 54 divide
both sides by sine of 54.
to get a by itself
and let's see what that comes out to so
8 sine 60.5
divided by sine of 54
we're getting 8.6
for this triangle and then over here for
the smaller triangle it will cross
multiply so a times the sine of 54.
equals eight times the sine of 11.5
divide both sides by the sine of 54.
and let's see what that comes out to
oops
divided by this oops let me try that
again I made a little mistake here so
when I was typing 8 sine of 11.5
divided by the sine of 54.
okay I'm getting about 1.97 which rounds
to 2.0 if we're rounding to the nearest
tenth so this is 2.0 and you solved the
triangle actually both triangles that
were possible and you got it so great
job if you're able to follow all the
topics in this comprehensive complete
guide to Law of Sines and law of cosines
if you want more practice follow me over
to a previous video I did talking about
Law of Sines the law of cosines right
there and I'll see you over in that
video